hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the matanovsky
gambit and this is a variation in the
owens defense
from black standpoint i actually don't
recommend playing it from white
standpoint you actually could run into
it
every now and then and so this video is
going to be more about an introduction
into the gambit
and how from white standpoint they
should optimally
play against it because it looks
extremely tricky
and many times if you don't know how to
play it you may fall into some of their
trap so it starts out with
e4 pretty common and then b6 this is the
owens defense
most times when players don't want to
counter attack in the center of the
board it's
usually correct just to control the
center yourself so e4
and then d4 bishop here to b7 a hyper
modern defense trying to control the
center with their minor
pieces and then bishop here to d3 you
could also play knight to c3 to protect
this light square that's being attacked
by
the bishop but many times players are
looking to play bishop here to d3 get
their knight involved into the game
castle on the king side get your king
safety ass
soon as possible and this is where the
madanovsky gambit comes into play
and it's with the move f5 and it looks
extremely tricky not something you would
expect to see too often and really the
thought behind this
is they want you to take here on f5 and
then they're going to play bishop takes
here on g2
attacking the rook here on h1
now unlike a lot of gambits where you
may not want to
take there's usually a better line in
this particular game but actually
recommend
taking that pawn here on f5 letting them
bring the bishop here to g2
attacking the rook if white plays
optimally which hopefully after this
video you will be able to
white will definitely be ahead so from
here
the best move is for white to play queen
to h5 the only legal option that black
has is to play pawn to g6 and then
white's going to capture here on
g6 now black pretty much has to play
bishop to
g7 here if they try something tricky
knight to
let's say f6 attacking the queen okay
well now we could just take with our
pawn here on
h7 this is check the only legal move
they have is to take our queen
but that's going to be checkmate with
bishop here to
g6 the king is just in a terrible spot
he is trapped
nowhere to go so that's not gonna work
can't bring the knight
here to f6 they do in fact need to bring
their bishop here
to g7 as soon as they do we're going to
take here on h7
and then from here the king is going to
come to f8 this
is also the only legal move that black
has so a lot of these are
forced there's not a lot of options that
black has
in this position this is where white can
play
sub-optimally but you'll definitely
understand how to play
correctly now white really should be
playing knight to f3 in this spot but
there's some other
tempting variations that you could look
at one of those might be hey
let's go ahead and take this knight here
on g8
this is a free piece hey my pawn is
going to be taken at some point
anyway so we might as well just go ahead
and take with our pawn
we can promote to a queen or a rook it
doesn't really matter we're forcing our
opponent
to go ahead and take material right here
but then the problem is
if you look at this position black's
just going to take this
rook here on h1 and so uh
they're also attacking with their rook
the queen here on h5
and so we have to retreat our queen back
and they play bishop takes here on h1
and then maybe knight to c3 how else do
you really attack here
pawn to e6 to prepare to get the queen
involved into the game this
also stops the knight coming down here
to d5
very important maybe bishop here to g5
attacking our queen but queen here to e8
and yes the king does not have any pawns
in front of it
but also black has a fine setup and i
i think uh black's gonna be fine in
this game so if we come back that's one
variation you could look at another one
might be okay let's just keep attacking
with the queen queen to
f5 may make sense
uh if you kind of look at it but then
you start to think okay well what is
black have here knight 2
f6 this stops the threat it also
prepares for rook taking here on h7 and
then you realize this is not really a
a very good move the only option you may
have you know bishop here 2h6
but then just rook takes here on h7 and
it's very
tough to see how white's going to
continue they're also going to lose this
rook here on
h1 so the best move in this position is
for white to play knight to f3
and this is where black has to play
correctly just to somewhat stay
in the game white's definitely going to
be ahead in
this game but if they look at this and
say okay my plan all along was to take
this rook here on h1
that is going to prove fatal for them
because
now we can just play the move knight to
e5 this is threatening the move
queen to f7 checkmate the only way to
stop this
is to play the move queen to ea any
other option they have
it's a pretty quick forced mate but if
they play queen
to h8 still very difficult for them to
hold on to things
we play pawn takes here on g8
check they pretty much have to take with
their rook here don't want to take with
the king
you can see that's going to be fatal
after the queen takes the queen here on
e8 um so pretty much have to take with
their rook here
but then after queen 2 f5 the only
option is bishop to
f6 and then bishop two h6 you could see
an exchange here
and then after the king takes now queen
down to h7 you can see the bishop on
d3 starting to play into the action here
defending the
queen so forcing the king to move and
now
bishop to g6 and this is going to be
lights out for black doesn't really
matter how they continue
sure they could take material and yes we
can take their queen automatically but
we don't have to because
we could take take with our pawn here on
e5 and you can see the queen is trapped
the queen can't go anywhere um or it is
going to fall and if it moves away
well then white has the threat of queen
to f7
checkmate so pretty much has to take
material and you can see
that is not going to end well so after
we play that knight to f3
they can't really take with their bishop
here on h1 they really need to be
playing the move
knight to f6 this is attacking our queen
so we definitely are going to move our
queen we're going to move it to
g6 now from here they have a couple
options same thing as before it would be
a mistake
if they take here on h1 but we are going
to play something slightly different
than moving our knights
instead we're going to play bishop down
here to h6 and this is going to be
lights out no real way for them to stop
this
you know they could take with their
bishop right here queen takes this is
check
king 2 f7 knight up here to
g5 lots of variations uh on how we could
finish this but after king 2e8 bishop to
g6 and this is going to be checkmate so
they can't really
take with their bishop here on h1 after
queen
to g6 you can see their their threat
that they wanted all along
in this game it was to play bishop to g2
and then take here on h1 and we are
putting them in so many situations where
anytime they do that it would be a
mistake and they would lose the game and
that's the whole point of
playing as white in this is knowing that
yes
i will go ahead and allow you to
continue down
your threat in this gambit but i'm never
actually going to allow you to take
the material here on h1 so after queen 2
g6 they really need to play the move
bishop takes here
on f3 that knight could be extremely
dangerous they just don't need to deal
with it so after that
then rook to g1 the rook is now safe
don't have to worry about the bishop
taking any more they could take with
their rook here this rook on h7 is
protected by the knight here on f6
but then the queen just comes back here
to g3 and this does a couple things once
a discovered attack the bishop here on
d3 is now attacking the rook here on h7
and also the queen now attacks this
bishop here on f3
so that is the madonovsky gambit
hopefully you enjoyed this video again
if you
see that from your opponent playing the
black pieces it's okay
you don't have to worry if they actually
play the move
pawn to f5 this is a mistake
on their part you can gladly accept it
let them take here on
g2 and then you can start the attack
with queen to h5
knowing that you're actually never going
to give up that rook here on h1 so thank
you guys so much for watching the video
if you enjoyed it if you wouldn't mind
hitting that like button
let me know if there is another video
you want me to make a video on
you can let me know in the comments
below or you can always email me as well
at the chess website
gmail.com but thanks again i'll see you
guys in the next video
you